and then the scary thing is and this is
another thing we've talked about a bit
on this podcast
and it is the
just the the complete
plasticity of people's brains and how
people can you get into an echo chamber
or you get you start following and
listening to certain things
it's going to take over your mind
and that's really really scary and
you know I I've been saying lately like
everyone's getting brainwashed I'm
getting brainwashed right now like
that's what's happening if you're
watching if you're listening if you're
opening your mind and letting other
things in there you're gaining
brainwashed you're and that's what's
happening to everybody all the time
that's what this I mean it's sort of
like it's a combination of brainwashing
and learning right if you're learning
you're kind of getting brainwashed
you're you're bringing in new ideas
but then you see people that are
learning ideas that aren't
essentially they're not good they're not
healthy and it's very very disturbing
and especially nowadays where that
brainwashing is in your pocket and at
any moment you can pull it out and you
can you can get brainwashed at any
moment and it's really really scary
um
and especially you know the the
moldability of children yeah
14 year olds 12 year olds 19 years old
you know it's like when I joined the
military
you're going to get brainwashed to some
level
I got in trouble when I went to boot
camp
um
actually I didn't get in trouble because
they didn't know who said it they we had
to fill out a form like about how boot
camp was going but it was Anonymous and
they wrote something like you know what
do you think of the program so far and I
wrote uh the brainwashing has been very
effective that's what I wrote how old
are you at the time
19 okay 18 or 19. yeah and
um
you know it's because I had a very
rebellious mind you know because I was
like what was I brainwashed by I was
brainwashed before I joined the military
by hardcore music and punk rock and like
anti-authoritarianism and so for me they
were trying to hit me with that stuff
and I kind of had some good resistance
to it so I kind of like oh they're
trying to brainwash me and then I kind
of made a joke about it the brainwashing
has been you know effective thus far
which
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to get you to like change your
brain a little bit and think in a
different way and and uh but at least I
I think I think I always had that
rebellious streak in me that always
questions everything and to this day
when I see something online I'm like oh
what's their angle yeah what's the angle
over there because there's everyone's
got an angle everyone does which is
which is disturbing
and um yeah so this is what's happening
now with kids and you can see it and
it's sad yeah it's so sad to see I
listened to a podcast that you did uh on
your podcast which is called the Tulsi
gabbard show with uh
was it is it called de-transitioning
yeah with Chloe Cole that was horrifying
exactly it was absolutely horrifying
um give us a quick brief on her so Chloe
Cole
um and I'm glad you mentioned that
because it's a perfect example of what
you're talking about here uh she grew up
in here in California
she was a tomboy as a kid growing up uh
love playing video games loved hanging
out with her brothers
and at 11 years old she got a smartphone
start an Instagram account
she was a tomboy didn't have many female
friends didn't really fit in much at
school so was looking for
some kind of companionship uh friendship
sense of belonging online
and the algorithms on Instagram
specifically she talks about immediately
started feeding her
um posts and and accounts of of young
girls and women who had who are
identifying as boys or men who are trans
or talking about how much happier they
were by doing so and and all of this and
then she had people around her who were
telling her well like if you're not
happy as you are then you're obviously a
boy stuck in a girl's body
um I'm gonna just be and just she's
she's 11. she's 11. 12. 11 years old
her name is Chloe at 12 years old she
told her parents she wrote them a long
letter and and the gist of it was I'm a
boy
and I want you to call me Leo
I encourage you to listen to the story
in her voice as she tells it because it
is
heartbreaking and so powerful
um if you watch it on YouTube you just
look into her eyes she's 18 now
and so but but
the the summary is
um she starts taking puberty blockers
when she's like 12 13 years old
and she was very certain about what she
wanted to do uh her parents were
naturally pretty confused and not
knowing what to do to best care for and
love their daughter
and so they went out and started looking
for health professionals to like hey
just like educate us talk talk us
through this what what are the
you know potential medical and health
ramifications of our daughter taking
these puberty blockers and and with the
exception of one endocrinologist who
told them like hey this we don't know
what the negative consequences might be
both in the short term and the long term
to this because there's just you know
it's not been studied very well there's
no long history of cases that that we
can point to to say well here's what you
can expect based on fact and Science and
so this endocrinologist is saying like
I would encourage you to think very
seriously before doing this because it
could end up badly essentially
um I forget what the name I think is a
gender specialist is what they're called
who are helping guide her through this
every other Medical Professional that
she went to see basically
urged her and encouraged her to move
forward with this
and ultimately told
her parents who were expressing some
concern and reservations
you have a choice
between having a live son or a dead
daughter
and Chloe says that up until that like
at that point she had never once had a
suicidal thought enter her mind so this
this warning and essentially this threat
that these medical professionals are
giving to this young girl's parents a
live son or a dead daughter you decide
was based on nothing
according to Chloe's medical history
fast forward she ends up getting a
double mastectomy when she's 15 years
old
to continue this transition
she talks about how they call it Top
surgery to try to you know soften what
what it really is
and it was after she got that surgery
that she had a realization I think she
was 16 at the time that she would know
she would never be able to breastfeed
her child ever she that had been taken
away from her because of this
this decision and you know she talks
about how she was asked at different
points along this path from when she was
12 12 through 15 like okay well here's
all these medical disclosures and you
know you might not be able to have kids
this could affect your fertility and at
12 years old she's like man I don't want
kids like how does a 12 year old girl
make that decision and then again at 15
before the surgery like okay well you
might not be able to do this or have
kids or breastfeed and you know again
children not being equipped to make
these decisions at 16 she
experienced incredible regret and
realized she'd make the biggest mistake
of her life
and then began to walk down that path of
quote unquote de-transitioning and she
talks about what that meant and
practical terms in her conversations
with her parents and friends and family
being completely shunned by this group
of you know people who are pushing this
this transgender Ideology Now now people
who celebrated her one day and the very
next day once she was like no I've made
the biggest mistake of my life
completely shunning her calling her
names giving her death threats online
doctors who had cared for her one day
the next day once she had made this
decision not returning phone calls or
telling her like you know she's still
having
um serious medical issues based on the
the mastectomy she had
that she can't figure out what to do
with and the doctor's like oh just put
some Vaseline on there
and and ultimately these doctors are not
providing her with the kind of care that
she needs or being responsive at all so
she she's actually filed a lawsuit
against these doctors and um Kaiser
um that
she dealt with along the way which is so
brave of her to do she's so incredibly
courageous to be doing what she's doing
and speaking out and actively
encouraging others to do the same so
that people are able to be better
informed but
that that social Contagion
uh that she talks really clearly about
of the algorithms having such a heavy
influence on her as a young girl
to ultimately bring her to make this
decision along with other other things
as well but
um
the the lack of
I guess I guess this phenomena in our
society right now where there's no open
conversation about this that she could
turn through that her family could turn
to to say to get a differing perspective
or differing view to where doctors feel
afraid to say anything about it I talked
to a friend of mine who's an ER doc
actually in California
and he said Tulsi I I you know would say
this off the Record but there are a lot
of kids who are coming into the ER
uh who are experiencing you know
suicidal thoughts or deep depression or
other medical issues because of this
uh transition of of people who are
similarly like Chloe Cole regretting
these decisions that they've made as
kids
and but nobody's talking about it you
know even from from the very top of of
you know where he works it was just like
all of a sudden okay hey guys we're
doing this now
and by the way it's a very
um
profitable Venture knowing that not only
the initial treatments but you're
basically once once somebody comes and
tells you they want to do this you're
talking about years of follow-on care
and drugs and all and so on and so forth
but there was no conversation about
um this at all because it's not allowed
if you even raise a question and say hey
is this really the best thing like our
kids really equipped to make this
decision when they're 11 or 12 years old
you're immediately labeled a transphobe
and how dare you not care for your kids
um in that podcast uh episode that I put
out there are actual videos from Boston
Children's Hospital as one example of
unfortunately many where they're
literally saying as soon as your child
is capable of expressing themselves
you'll see signs of them uh
you know deciding what their gender
identity is like before they can even
use words and speak any kind of language
that you look at like gestures and you
look at all these different things and
you just you see how dangerous this is
when critical thinking is like it's
discouraged asking questions is
discouraged having differing points of
view is discouraged and I think even
using the word discouraged is is putting
it lightly people get banned on social
media get their accounts
you know suspended indefinitely for
asking questions or saying hey this is
not appropriate for kids again then you
let add on the layer of government
and this is where things get so
dangerous is that you know Chloe
mentions that she knows people
personally
who parents who've had their kids taken
away from them simply because they
refuse to
call them by a name or pronoun different
than the one they were given at Birth
by Child Protective Services by the
government
and this is this is the very real
consequence of
people
just being willing to go along
and maybe it's like I don't know this
doesn't seem right but at least it's not
happening to me or my kids or my family
so I'm just going to put my head in the
you know in the sand and not pay
attention
um but there's there's so many different
factors you start looking at it I
mentioned parents going and you know
protesting like no you know what I don't
want my seven-year-old kid being given
books to read at school about like well
tell me what your sexuality is or tell
me what your gender identity is I I
didn't you know I heard parents talk
about this stuff and I thought gosh you
know this is really concerning and then
I met with with a bunch of parents in
Virginia who've been on the
um
a group called parents defending
education have been kind of on the front
lines of this fight nationally and they
brought a stack of books and showed me
and and there was one in particular that
um it it it was a graphic novel for
middle schoolers
and I I had never seen such sexually
graphic images ever in my life
and this is something that's being given
to kids to help them you know figure out
you know what their sexuality is and
it's um
it's really disturbing that we live in a
society today
where this Open Marketplace of ideas is
not allowed to occur
and it's not allowed to occur because we
have people in power who are using the
lovers of government
working with people in the media and in
big Tech
to control
speech
and to influence
our society